well joining me now is the shadow
minister for domestic violence and
safeguarding jess phillips and uh well
jess we've been slightly overtaken by
events because you came on to talk about
the latest in the
uh
chris uh pinscher issue but i mean it's
it does look as though he's in serious
trouble now what do you make of uh the
last uh well the two resignations
i i think that boris johnson is probably
done for but this is boris johnson and
he doesn't live by the standards um set
to to most people so uh we shall see i
don't see how ministers
and secretaries of state can read sajid
javid's letter and see rishi sunak's
resignation and not think that staying
is to dip their hands in in blood people
like that the home secretary staying
when the scandal is about sex uh crimes
and abuse which she is meant to be
across similarly with the justice
secretary i i hear dominic raab and
quasi quartet have both said that they
they are going to stay
but i just don't think that holds um
until well you know the next half an
hour but you seem to suggest uh at the
beginning you think he could survive
this do you
look boris johnson is uh a man who in
the face of absolute calamity still
believes his own hype so uh i imagine
that unlike most people who would act
with dignity with grace uh whether that
was you know whether i agree with them
or not uh theresa may posed her no
confidence vote which she won by a
bigger margin than boris johnson uh
david cameron post the the referendum
result uh even margaret thatcher if i'm
remembering back to when i was just a
girl um boris johnson has no dignity he
has no standards these things don't
affect him in the same way uh that they
affect others and so boris johnson will
today just be thinking about how he can
save boris johnson and somehow in that
he is uniquely uh he's uniquely talented
yeah i mean he did admit when he spoke a
few minutes ago he did admit that it was
a mistake
to appoint chris pincher and he
apologized um
do you think that was enough at all
no i don't think it was enough uh he
also has said today that he's forgotten
uh that he was told that chris pincher
um was uh a sort of serial perpetrator
of these events and had undertaken a
formal investigation he said that he had
forgotten well as somebody who has had
many of these cases brought to my door
you don't forget so boris johnson has
throughout this process as found by lord
macdonald who came out and basically
skewered him red-handed for the lies he
didn't know a specific case he didn't
know any cases at all he didn't know of
a formal investigation but all of those
things have proved to be untrue so when
boris johnson says he wished it had been
different that it was a mistake this is
just more boris johnson lies he'd do the
same again in fact i wouldn't be
surprised as he was thinking about
whether he should make him the
chancellor
but it is possible i suppose that you
know boris johnson as he claimed or his
number 10 claim didn't immediately
recall
the briefing that he had is it possible
no it's absolutely not possible i'm
afraid to say you know we all have busy
lives and lots of difficult things and
you know he is the prime minister he
also has hundreds of people who work on
those busy lives for him hundreds of
other advisers to remind him of things
um it's absolutely not true i'm sorry
it's just it's it's
the story has changed so much to the
point that boris johnson has i mean it's
like in a soap opera where you know
they're trying to bring somebody back
from the dead and they have to do it in
a dream sequence that is what they're i
forgot offen uh defenses it doesn't wash
with me
i'm afraid to say because everything
boris johnson has said in the last three
days has been a lie this is a lie as
well what about uh implications for
labor if he does go i mean he's been
polling pretty badly the tories have
been struggling in the polls losing by
elections i mean a new leader whoever it
is would have a honeymoon period and
you know may perform certainly in the
polls
possibly you know much better than boris
johnson
oh and like boris johnson i'm not only
interested in what's the best for me and
with self-interest
of course it would be better for me and
my political party if boris johnson
stayed in post but it wouldn't be better
for my constituents and it wouldn't be
better for the country
and so the labour party has to beat
whoever the labour party has to beat and
it has to do that on its merits and that
is what it will do
what are the calculations that uh other
cabinet ministers will be making in the
next couple of hours what
what what are your thoughts on that
well yeah you have to decide whether
he's going to survive and you want to
keep your job but regardless of your
morality there are some who have no um
illusions of grandeur in the future
and so they might just want to plod
along and keep their ministerial
salaries while their reputations and the
reputation of their political party goes
to the dogs there's no doubt going to be
some of those but actually the
calculation now is i mean obviously you
always want to be the first or in the
first tranche um at the very least now
it just might look like you were
following and you didn't have the
principles in the first place but the
reality is is there's some good people
in that in boris johnson's cabinet i
know that those who've had to go out on
the television recently aren't
necessarily the best examples of that
but um
you you stay and you you're basically
saying that boris johnson is bigger than
the conservative party bigger than the
country and you dip your hands in his
blood
and just finally um just phillips the
letter this morning which prompted quite
possibly these other two letters of
resignation from lord macdonald what did
you make of that
well
what i made of it was that it must have
taken a huge amount for lord macdonald
to write that letter civil servants
you know across newspapers and news you
know people bash them all the time and
they don't have a right to reply and
they they they serve studiously often
and they don't speak out so for him to
speak out i think is absolutely a
remarkable thing but when you sign up to
a code of honor as we all meant to in
public life if only boris johnson would
just do the same you sign up one of the
things that you sign up to is honesty
and integrity these are the nolan
principles of public life he is a
serving lord he was a serving civil
servant he signs up to those principles
and he lived by them and i would
encourage every single person who has to
sign up to the nolan principles to do
the same okay jess phillips thanks for
being with us